the fans must have been going bonkers
did you feel the love out there oh yeah
man it's a special this is a really
special place to be I've been doing
comic-con for I mean pretty consistently
for 20 years maybe 15 years he's the
Stargate and you know Conan and Drogo
and I'm a superhero so it's kind of its
kind of home and I was loving one Hall H
and it's really it's just fun showing
them all the little presents we have to
bring you know all the hard work and you
get with the people that love it the
most so considering all the time that
you've spent here and the connection you
have to the fans what feels different
this time I'm I finally made it yeah
it's been a long road it's been six
years probably since I was in saks
office so till now that's my movie so I
mean that's probably one you're working
with this cast that is absolutely
phenomenal when you're when you're on
set or or in the water let's say working
with these people what's it like are you
learning from each other you just having
a good time oh yeah our cast is pretty
it's like family so for instance
Nicole's probably one of the greatest
actor anyone that I've ever worked with
I've never seen anyone with that kind of
work ethic and to constantly just
just always evolving and making things
new and and you know we did many many
takes on under extreme conditions and it
was just beautiful to watch I almost
feel like a spectator cuz we're that
close just watching her she's a pro man
so and then Patrick it's unbelievable
you know yah yah just watchin him he's
just so II just like he's new kind of
into everything he's just passionate
about everything and I'm kind of it's
it's beautiful you dodge birthday's
coming up in a couple days or anything
here anything a comic-con that she
wanted specifically it has got it she
just got her Harry Potter Legos oh yeah
she did yes she's he we just went to
Harry Potter and she's a big fan of that
so yeah yeah yeah we'll be doing that
tonight yeah